this isn't just some random murder  it's an extermination  dozens of witnesses all over gotham  no discernible pattern i can see when  the streets burn the corpses of our  favorite heroes  who can save us  hello  gotham  batgirl here  firefly must be stopped but i can't do  it alone i don't exist  i'm not even here get it together man  we're all that's left and right here  right now  the universe needs you everybody's got a  mask on  i got one you got one  every now and then  it slips a little bit  there's good and there's evil and evil  must be  90 punished dollars  up in flames the police have got it  wrong firefly was just a decoy  but if not him  then who  were  the warner brothers and you're  a writer  [Applause]  you